[Music]
foreign
[Music]
usually software Engineers are some of
the best paid employees in the entire
world they have a great job prospects
and some of them are even able to earn
seven figures now of course there are
people on the other side of the spectrum
as well who are freelancing and end up
barely making ends meet but the people
who are really in a sticky situation are
the ones that are in the middle these
guys generally work for extremely
well-known Brands like EA Activision
Blizzard and Ubisoft but they're often
treated like Amazon warehouse workers
this is quite surprising given that
software developers are white-collar
workers and are essential in bringing
these games to Market not to mention it
the number of games that these companies
release per year has reduced
substantially so you would think that
software Engineers would have less on
their plate but this is not the case in
fact software engineers at these
companies often work 12 hours per day
six days a week and that when a game is
getting close to its launch day this
ramps up to as much as 13 hours per day
and 7 days per week this isn't some sort
of new discovery either this has been
common practice within the gaming
industry dating as far back as 2004. in
fact EA has already settled to class
action lawsuits regarding labor abuse
but 20 years later nothing much has
changed at EA and this is the same case
with Activision Blizzard Ubisoft and
even epic games given how demanding
these companies are you would think that
they at least pay well that must be why
people are sticking around right well
that's not true either while these
companies do definitely pay a livable
wage and it's nowhere close to what
these software Engineers could be
earning it if they spent their efforts
elsewhere take Ubisoft for example
entry-level engineers at Ubisoft earn 54
000 per year while senior software
Engineers earn eighty seven thousand
dollars per year this sounds good until
you realize that Google pays their
entry-level engineers at 180 000 per
year and their senior engineers at 326
000 per year so here's how these game
developers trap engineers and get away
with working them to the bone while
paying them at below Market wages
yeah
you commonly share the career advice of
Follow Your Passion and that if you do
something you love you'll never work a
day of your life but this advice
completely falls apart when you're
factor in companies that abuse their
employees passion the gaming industry is
just one example of this but this issue
is present throughout the entire job
market the companies with the best
working conditions are generally those
with products that people aren't exactly
passionate about I mean I don't think
anybody is particularly passionate about
writing algorithms that collect other
people's data so companies like Facebook
and Google have to pay larger salaries
and offer better perks to get people to
jump through some moral hoops and to do
work that doesn't exactly excite them on
the flip side companies like Tesla and
SpaceX are able to pay far lower
salaries and demand much more because
the people who work there are extremely
passionate about the final product and
the company Mission game companies that
very much fall on this side of the
spectrum this software Engineers that
apply to these companies are generally
Avid Gamers themselves and they're
usually super motivated to bring games
that gave them so much joy to other
players this sentiment usually gets them
trapped into a vicious loop as one game
developer put it and it tends to be more
fun at the beginning of a project and a
lot of drudgery at the end just when you
think you might want to switch jobs
you're given a new project and your
passion for the art is reignited and
before you know it you keep going down
the same Rabbit Hole over and over and
over again one EA executive has even
admitted that toxic environments are
inevitable within large Publishers and
the worst part is that the class action
lawsuits that we talked about arguably
just made things worse for these
Developers for example the second
lawsuit against EA resulted in many
employees being reclassified as hourly
workers instead of salary workers the
reasoning behind this is that hourly
workers would have to be paid overtime
while salaried workers did not this
seems like a good thing until you
realize that hourly workers are
ineligible for stock based compensation
which is where the money is really at
and Google for example while over half
of principal Engineers compensation is
in the form of stock and that's not even
accounting for stock growth we all know
that the fan companies have killed it
over the past 10 years but some of these
game developers have actually grown even
more than Finn companies EA for example
has grown 10x in the past 10 years while
Activision Blizzard has grown 5x and
much of this growth is attributable to
the work being done by game developers
yet many of them won't even benefit from
the company doing so well given that
they're treated as hourly workers so
unfortunately it doesn't seem like
following their passion has actually
worked out all that well
foreign
get stuck in this vicious Loop for their
entire careers some do try to look for
other opportunities but it doesn't take
them long to realize that they're kind
of stuck here's the thing while EA and
Google both need software Engineers the
work that Engineers do at these
companies couldn't be more different at
EA software Engineers are primarily
going to be working to develop things
like Collision detection Collision
response physics animations and user
inputs meanwhile at Google software
Engineers are primarily going to be
working on search algorithms sorting
through data debugging production issues
and identifying edge cases virtually
none of this has to do with the
programming great physics or fluid game
mechanics and while most programmers
agree that game development is a way
harder companies that don't hire
employees based on how hard their
previous work was companies hire based
on how relevant and applicable the
previous work was so it's typically
quite difficult for engineers that spend
their entire careers in game development
to switch to traditional software
engineering this issue is only made it
worse with time as a software Engineers
progressed through the Rings their jobs
have less to do with coding it and more
to do with the systems design and
leveraging it Enterprise Solutions this
includes things like Google Cloud
platform Microsoft Azure Amazon web
services Oracle apps sap Salesforce and
so on with that being said when a game
developer was a 10 years experience
interviews for a software engineering
position the questions are going to be
less about reversing linked lists and
creating binary trees and more about how
familiar they are with the sap s4hana or
AWS the developers that are competing
against the game developer are likely to
have a traditional background and will
thus be able to answer these questions
much better now you might be asking why
not just apply for a lower level
position well the problem is that it's
even harder to get these jobs because
you come off as being overqualified in
an Ideal World recruiters we take a
closer look at the game developers
background and let them interview for
the more Junior role so that they can
learn the ropes on the tech side of
things but more times than not companies
dismiss such applicants as Engineers
with a lack of trajectory if a given
developer has 10 years of experience but
they still aren't familiar with systems
design or Enterprise Solutions the
applicant comes off as someone who isn't
growing and learning and that no one
wants to hire someone that isn't growing
and learning so while some game
developers try venturing out they're
often hit with a bunch of rejection and
usually they end up staying at their
current role or switching to yet another
game company in the cycle just continues
foreign
news though as there are a few game
companies that prioritize employees
mental health one of these companies is
Riot games who is the developer behind
League of Legends and the valorant Not
only does survived games rank favorably
when it comes to workplace culture they
actually rank at the top in fact 95 of
ride employees say that it's a great
place to work while the average for a US
company is only 57 but even Riot Falls
victim to one of the biggest issues
within the game development industry
which is a gender-based discrimination
just a few years ago by its entire
leadership was men and they actually got
sued for discrimination they ended up
settling for a hundred million dollars
and since then Riot has Diversified
their leadership to include 20 women but
it doesn't seem like the sentiment has
changed all that much yes Riot has
expanded their diversity but it appears
that this is more of a show to appease
chords than a true shift in culture a
similar situation can be found at
Ubisoft as well in fact an internal
survey at Ubisoft revealed that 25 of
employees had seen or experienced
workplace misconduct in addition to this
one in five said that they didn't feel
fully respected or safe in the work
environment since then Ubisoft has gone
ahead and fired a bunch of their
executive team but to be honest there is
not much that these companies can do
because that's not where the issue
really stems from this issue really
stems from The Gaming Community itself
which can oftentimes be quite toxic this
isn't just limited to gaming per se
basically any online community where you
can mask your identity is pretty toxic
and a given that The Gaming Community is
likely the largest community in which
this is possible it's no wonder that
there are also arguably the most toxic
of course this isn't to say that all
gamers are toxic the vast majority of
gamers are perfectly normal people but
it just takes a few bad actors here and
there to gain a bad reputation
and if you want an example of just how
toxic online communities can get I
recommend checking out the YouTube
channel mask Arab the YouTuber basically
goes on to Amigo addressed as an Arab
and it basically everyone is racist to
him and it's actually pretty funny
because the YouTuber generally roasts
these people pretty hard but it's also
sad that people can be so toxic when you
combine this online toxicity with the
fact that hardcore gaming communities
are dominated by men it's not surprising
that women working at these game
companies often have to deal with a
bunch of discrimination and a toxicity
foreign
most game companies are nostalgic to
many of us as we grew up seeing their
loading animations over and over again
and many of us have sunk more hours into
these games than we'd like to admit
considering this it's not surprising
that many of these people would like to
enter game development themselves and to
bring joy to a new generation of people
but unfortunately the industry is not
all that great first of all given that
you're driven by passionate it's easy
for these Mega companies to take
advantage of that and demand more work
while paying relatively less and if you
get for Android game development career
and it's often hard to switch to a
traditional software engineering role as
you often don't possess the knowledge
and expertise that would be expected of
someone at your level and if you're a
woman all of these issues are just going
to be Amplified even more so what's the
solution to this well theoretically
speaking it's actually really simple
instead of only following a passion the
key would be to follow a combination of
a passionate and opportunity if you're a
programmer aren't interested in game
development the answer might be to join
twitch or Discord these companies deal
with much more traditional engineering
skills like integration with AWS so
you'd be able to participate in it and
to grow with the Gaming Community while
not being subject to its various
pitfalls and if enough people start
thinking like this and they move away
from traditional development companies
then maybe the situation it may just get
better but that's just what I think
would you want to be a game developer
comment that down below also drop a like
if you hope that conditions at these
gaming companies get better and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community it suggest for your video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions as you answered until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one